I'm actually really interested in in
your philanthropy with Yale and how
you've worked with the aya so I'm just
recently working with aya as well for
the reunions at the end of semester so
I'm really interested in that
organization but I wanted to ask you a
little bit about your involvement with
Yale women and I'm actually involved in
several women's organizations here on
campus and you know one is a Greek
organization and another one is the
Women's Leadership Conference and
women's leadership here at Yale I was
wondering I don't know a lot about Yale
women and i would i'd really like to
find out more about that so what kinds
of philanthropic efforts has has your
has have you been involved with with
feel women well yo M is very new we just
launched it in december so we don't have
any specific philanthropic efforts that
have come out of the organization but
yeah women I see as it's almost like a
mini aya when you think about their
50,000 via women alums and across the
world and from graduate the graduate
school freshman school graduate school
professional schools and the college and
we have a strategic plan which you can
beam which talks about this piece that
you're talking about philanthropy giving
back one of our pillars is contribution
two of them are actually contributions
to society and contributions to Yale and
I find that the women this is this group
has come out of a number of years of
people feeling like we needed to have a
women's group because in a way it's the
same thing I talked about before when I
get together with other young women it's
interesting and stimulating and exciting
and we just love conversing with each
other no matter what class were in what
you know in terms of age group or
society or profession so in a way it
seems self-serving you know it's what do
we get out of this we get out of this
real enjoyment of being together but the
same common themes seem to arise in
terms of what people want to do they
want to get back we want to mentor Yale
students we want to mentor other alums
we're interested in lifelong learning we
do want to develop ways to be
philanthropic ourselves to partner with
other nonprofit organizations to to give
back to our communities so building
community that's another one
pillars actually so so it's very
exciting we're very much in the startup
phase of it but and what year did you
say you were I'm a sophomore okay so
you're already a member because if
you've been in a degree program at Yale
for one semester you're considered an
alarm all alums and you're already a
member feeling I was going to ask us you
as well how do you integrate the younger
population of Yale of Yale women and how
can how can my my friends and I get
involved well we have a committee on
campus partnerships we're already
looking to look to the students and to
and other campus organizations actually
probably some other people you work for
any organizations are aware of us and
have started working with us but you
know it's the same it's part of what of
my answer before what we'd like to do is
make people aware that we exist do some
work while we're while you're on campus
maybe when you're home for Spring Baker
in the summertime get involved with
whatever's in your region and you know
part of it is an awareness that when you
come out if when you come out after
senior year if you're already aware of
all the alumni opportunities we're much
more likely to get you involved which is
you know it really the answer your
question